[Musique]
on va descendre c'était en avait autant
de français que deux belges mais là mois
de janvier normalement c'est censé être
une période calme et des grâces à nos
petits belges est bon on a beaucoup
beaucoup de boulot vraiment la semaine
prochaine tous combattu désolé désolé
merci beaucoup bonne journée merci à
on fait le maximum en ce moment les
seuils de refuser le moins de personnes
possible c'est de combler tout le monde
malheureusement les couvre-feux à 18
heures pour les obliger ferment à 18h ça
se voit les hommes il se coupe les
cheveux à peut-être de mm partout sur la
tête
les femmes elles ont des repousses de
mèches assez importante
les belges viennent ici pour se faire
coiffer ben ça se voit beaucoup moins je
sais qu'il ya quand même une économie
souterraine qui est fait en belgique
parce que je sais que certains coiffeurs
coiffe de façon cachée je pense que
c'est essentiel dans le sens où si on
n'a pas bien coiffé on sent pas
forcément bien dans notre peau
mais pour le bien-être des gens c'est ce
qu'il faut faire et moi je le conseille
de venir
je ne suis pas vraiment hors la loi oui
effectivement je ne respecte pas les
règles de mon pays mais je passe donc la
frontière pour me sentir mieux
mon look dette important quand même dans
mon travail et donc je suis obligé je
peux pas rester comme ça
des dames qui viennent de namur toutes
les semaines on kalfon trois quarts
d'heure une heure toutes les semaines
faire l'ordre chez nous tant mieux on a
gagné des clientes
mais l'autre côté peuvent pas travailler
alors qu'ils font la même chose que nous
dans les mêmes règles seba pas logique
du tout on a l'impression qu'on ne peut
plus que travailler à l'eswc il
cherchait vraiment la nourriture et puis
pour le reste tout ce qui fait un peu
partie du loisir ou de bien-être c'est
terminé doit tout mes clients neige
quand elles me disent qu'elles regardent
la télé dans l'eau toutes les personnes
politiques aidant gouvernement belge ils
ont tous une belle tête en a pas
beaucoup qui sont passés à la télé avec
des racines ou des cheveux longs ou
voilà on pouvoir est en droit d'aller
chez le coiffeur et que la population
belge
elle n'a pas droit